there's such a reservoir of goodwill for
you you've been in the business such a
long time and that was spontaneous
people just love you you come out
they're very happy to see you it makes
me feel great and and and I've been
lucky I've been involved in since a kid
and something that I've always loved I
always knew I loved it there was never
any confusion about it and I and I'm
still really enjoying it and of course
the energy that I get from from starting
is a little kid we all everyone as you
know remember you initially on on
Mayberry right you know under show lady
Griffith Show and and as just as a
little kid I also knew that you were I
think your career started in this studio
on this stage 15 didn't you shoot the
music man here as I did how old are you
when you shot we did the music man I had
actually started the andy griffith show
so it wasn't the very beginning but it
was sort of my first big high-profile
feature and i think they shot in 1961 so
i was you know i was 7 just turned 7 you
were right here you were right do you
remember coming to this building i
remember coming to this lot and we shot
on a few stages but there's a plaque out
there that i noticed on my way in I
always makes me feel feel-good brings
back a lot of memories yeah it's uh they
have a little plaque outside that has
the list of all of the great movies that
have been shot here and then it's funny
you'll be looking at it and just
incredible movies like classic movies
that you're looking at that you remember
and then they'll be always a couple in
there we were like oh my god
biodome three was shot here you know
and now and now Conan yes now Conan yes
dragging it down you remember like I
think you also shot do you remember any
of the lines that you had I had to sing
you know and I think that in retrospect
knowing what I now know I think they
thought it was adorable that I couldn't
carry a tune
right but you know right here we shot
the Wells Fargo wagon number was out
here yeah right oh the Wells Fargo wagon
is a calm and rounded for someone who is
no relation but it could be something
stressful that's that's fantastic you
know what's ever win an award and again
yeah I know it's great is that you your
career was so successful but if it
hadn't been you'd have been touring the
country doing that song as you know the
dope that you are now maybe I would have
moved up to the Robert Preston part you
know professor Harold Hill you'd be a
great professor I've always wanted to
play professor Howard Hill yeah just for
the trouble song I would just do the
trouble song oh and I would I remember
that well either you're closing your
eyes to a situation you do not wish to
acknowledge or you're not aware the
caliber of disaster to camp or the
presence of a pool table in your
community you got to my friend right
here I say right here in River City
about trouble and then you go off and
running and I would have a blast
I want that part we make cream in fact
you I gotta get off this death ship I
want to see him I want to Conan I want
to I want to see Conan starring in
movies don't you want to see him yeah
they're like anything to get him out of
here TBS is like when maybe we'll give
him that chin
well that is proof positive that you
can't induce people to lie their asses
off because I don't think they'd pay to
see you I think they meant it for that
moment I'm gonna cut that part out of
the interview we're gonna use the top
part
you